[Music]
there's a universal belief that music
heals it doesn't hurt if you can have
fun in the process
the magic of dance has proved to be a
Lifeline against depression and thoughts
of self-harm salsa was the only thing
that could make me smile all those days
I was battling
fighting with my demons with my past
with my everything salsa was the only
thing that makes me feel like living
he believes the best way to feel good is
to do something physical and in this
case attach a beat to it
[Music]
there's no space for you to think about
your sorrow because one you're thinking
about the music
you're thinking about
um
the counts the Rhythm
adindu has been giving free salsa
classes since 2007.
with most Friday nights attracting 40
people or more many are finding the
dancing more than just therapeutic so
help me relieve stress it doesn't help
me build relationship between people
I've met new friends and the dance gives
me fit
health professionals say mental
illnesses often misunderstood in
Nigerian Society it is not a spiritual
problem it is a health problem you know
people always easily identify
um physical health okay I have malaria I
have diabetes habitation I think it's
normal but then when it comes to their
brain being ill they suffering to find
another way to explain it away so now
that it is one more illness that is from
my body malfunctioning in this case the
brain
Salsa's fun and enjoyable moves or
helping to break down barriers spread
awareness and change perceptions about
mental illness Michael Apple Al Jazeera